they're gonna be taking on master and
commander zach grink he's had some
pretty good success throughout his
entire career
against the green and gold
but zach starts out well slow curveball
getting lauriano
one two three first with a strikeout to
end it so a man in scoring position and
two out for julie guriel scoreless ball
game bottom of the first
now here's the 1-1 pitch on the way to
guriel frankie throws and it's a breaky
ball hit down to short up with it
simeon has it throws to first for the
out and the inning is over
guerrillas out 6-3 the astros fail to
score
there's the grinky curveball and
grossman strikes out
at 67 miles an hour it's baffling
there's really no other way to to
describe it so that strikeout ties in
with david cohen
for 25th on the all-time
strikeout list
there's a shot diving play that's tommy
la stella
tucker hit it right on the button it's
all right we got a guy there
lay out for me one time 100 miles an
hour off the bat at tucker and
la stella lay out
that a baby postseason possibilities
let's remember
that this is all being done without a
key cog and chris davis having the
production
this one's hit to right center and it's
hit well and
that baby's gone so what a welcome sight
that is
chris davis a home run to right center
field just like riding the bike
kite you know the man's got the ability
to power the baseball out of
any yard in the world
[Applause]
3-2 pitch swing and a miss slider down
and away and that
is out number one third k
that's two thousand six hundred and
sixty nine now for
greinke and he has surpassed david cohen
for 25th on the all-time list
don't get a whole lot of opportunities
against guys like grinky
they ace have one here
and that's a base hit left field so a
curveball and
lorianna was able to wait and he rips it
in the left for a two out rbi hit
and the a's lead two nothing so brantley
with his second double he's covered both
lines
and now it's second and third for
guerrilla
cannon coming in and cannon's got it so
frankie mata slaps his glove
so a little work for frankie montauk so
with a one-out here's reddick who had a
base hit in the second inning
still on the backhand it's still a
frozen time to get ready for the second
hour
maldonado first pitch to pinder bender
throws in time and frankie
gets out of the jam so the astros will
bring the infield in
le stella a fly ball the left and a walk
that ball's hit pretty hard
line drive caught by correa who shows
the ball
just in case anyone was uncertain zach
wasn't thrilled with the pitch but he
got away with one it's a shutout fifth
astros down two nothing
here's michael bradley he has a couple
of doubles in this game
and he hits this ball hard to right
field going all the way back and looking
up
that ball is gone michael brantley
ties the game up at two oh did the
astros need that home run
in the bottom half of the fifth inning
brantley
now three for three makes it a 2-2 game
with his fourth home run of the year
second straight hitting the astros will
have to bring the infield in with one
away and a runner on third
roseman a strikeout and a ground out to
short
center field springer coming in springer
dives and he caught it
he gets up are they saying no they say
it's going to be a base hit laureato
comes in to score
it's going to be a base hit for grossman
and the a's take the lead
they shift the infield for chris that
one is driven right center field
nobody's going to get it
grossman to third they're going to wave
at home
correa is not going to make a throw
chris davis with a huge two out rbi
double
and it's 4-2 the a's lead
on the ground correa great play throw
home
out at home played correa the
excellent play defensively and maldonado
had to come across for the tag
carlos correa has been playing an elite
shortstop defense all year long so
two away and here's bregman diaz the
runner in first
one-two pitch got him swinging and
that's the ball game
so liam hendricks strikes out springer
and bregman with a runner at first
to end the game